[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de face aux territoires sur tv5 monde
avec nos partenaires ouest france le
groupe nice matin nous comprend senti
aussi dans les départements et
territoires d'outre-mer et puis 20
minutes qui nous accompagnent dans cette
émission également en tant que
partenaire et vous pouvez regarder le
direct sur ouest france.fr sur
nicematin.com par contre est sûre
franceantilles.fr avec un léger décalage
dû aux fuseaux horaires aux antilles mon
invité ce matin c'est nadia et bonjour
nadia et vous êtes ministre chargé de la
ville ministre de la ville comme dit
emmanuel macron le président de la
république en vous qualifiant
malheureusement l'actualité est triste
ce matin une nouvelle fusillade à
marseille dans le quartier la visitation
dans la nuit c'est dans le 14e
arrondissement de la capitale des
bouches du rhône à 21h30 exactement un
mort il a 18 ans et un blessé mineur je
crois qu'il a il a 17 ans nadia et c'est
une triste
nuit à marseille j'allais dire une de
plus puisque il y a eu énormément il y a
énormément de problèmes à marseille on y
reviendra bien sûr tout au long de cette
émission eric zemmour hier soir dans une
émission de télévision
qualifié d'ailleurs ces quartiers dont
nous avons parlé tout au long de cette
émission de far west
c'est exact
d'abord encore un drame effectivement
dans les quartiers nord de marseille
cette fusillade qui visiblement à
l'heure où on se parle et d'après les
premiers éléments serait un règlement de
comptes vous savez
qualifiés des quartiers avec des noms
comme cela ne rend absolument service à
personne et surtout n'est absolument pas
efficace sur la guerre que nous devons
mener contre ces trafiquants et les
séparatistes en tout genre aujourd'hui
qui gangrènent une partie de nos
quartiers en france donc oui
effectivement il ya des difficultés oui
à une concentration de difficultés dans
ces territoires sur sur cette question
de la sécurité est notre main ne tremble
pas sur cette question va revenir on
parle de roubaix aussi un instant à un
reportage de m6 a souligné il ya une
semaine l'emprise de l'islam radical
re lannoy à roubaix
dites nous la vérité sur ces quartiers
dont on a dit qu'ils étaient de non
droit est ce qu'il y a d'autres roubaix
en france madame la ministre chargée de
la ville déjà je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de qualifier des territoires
comme cela parce que c'est encore les en
dehors de la qualification c'est un
instant que savez je vais vous dire
pourquoi cyril viguier c'est important
parce que le fait de m finalement tout
tout tout une ville dans le même sac et
bien c'est ne pas rendre service à la
cause c'est même être compris de contre
productif puisque ça sert le discours
justement de ces rares asiatique
d'autres d'eau qu'il est vous qu'il est
bien placé pour priver les cartes bien
sûr géographiques françaises il est
important il y en at il d'autres il est
important de bien qualifier ce qui se
passe dans ces territoires pour pouvoir
apporter une réponse efficace cru et oui
si répliqué le séparatisme existe dans
notre territoire national dans les
quartiers dans certaines campagnes et et
là dessus nous menons une action
déterminée vous savez qui
quel gouvernement a voté une loi pour
s'attaquer au fond au respect des
principes républicains si ce n'est notre
gouvernement donc oui il ya des
territoires oui ils sont identifiés
évidemment roubaix en fait partie
d'autres quartiers en font partie hélas
uci là aussi nous menons une action
déterminée pour à la fois réaffirmé nos
principes républicains et à la fois ne
pas jeter l'opprobre sur toute une
partie des habitants pour changer
justement qui leur colle à nadia
ministre chargé de la ville est notre
invité politique ce matin en face aux
territoires azotés rac qui est un
champion de mma de sports de combat qui
est un marseillais qui est un habitant
des quartiers
il a failli tourner mal son frère a été
assassiné devant lui il a tourné mieux
tourner bien il a réalisé au moment de
ce drame que sa vie ne pouvait pas aller
dans ce sens et c'est grâce au sport il
ya une question à vous poser depuis
marseille azotés rac je travaille dans
l'éducation populaire
et
en particulier dans la prévention et
j'aide les jeunes à se réinsérer avec le
sport de combat et la question que
j'aimerais bien vous posez madame la
ministre c'est que diriez vous à ces
jeunes là pour pouvoir les motiver ces
jeunes qui n'ont pas de qui n'ont pas
d'objectifs et à cause de ça ils se
tournent vers des choses pas très
pas très bonne pour eux
d'abord bonjour azotés rac et merci pour
cette question ce que j'ai envie de
répondre à ces jeunes c'est qu'il n'ya
pas de fatalité aujourd'hui dans notre
pays qu'au xxième siècle en france on
peut réussir on peut réussir si on suit
cette voie républicaine cette offre
républicaine et pour cela nous
multiplions les moyens nous multiplions
les moyens sur la prévention et j'ai été
vraiment ravi d'entendre ce mot de
prévention parce que c'est une politique
nous avons trop souvent écartés pour
remettre dans le droit finalement
raccroché certains jeunes qui sont en
marge de la société à ce qui fait
société et donc nous multiplions les
moyens en matière de prévention un
soutien massif aux associations nous
redéployons des éducateurs et des
médiateurs aussi formés à la prévention
spécialisée les jours tous nous mettons
l'emploi et l'éducation au coeur de
notre action collet on doit y revenir
dans un an voilà donc pas de fatalité
c'est le message que j'ai adressé à ces
jeunes la république elle est là et elle
va justement vous aider vous accompagner
à la réussite voilà dans un instant
stéphane bern et de ouest france nous
rejoint sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour stéphane bern et vous êtes le
rédacteur en chef délégué de ouest
france à paris bonjour
on commence et ben écoutez on va
commencer par une question sur le bilan
du quinquennat a on se souvient du
rapport borloo en 2018 qui avait été
proposé plusieurs mesures un grand plan
qui avait été écarté à l'époque par
emmanuel macron deux ans plus tard lors
de son discours des mureaux en octobre
2020 le même chef de l'état dit que 75%
des mesures de ce plan ont été adoptés
ce qui avait fait beaucoup réagir à ce
moment là là on est à la fin du
quinquennat la réalité c'est quoi qu'est
ce qui a été fait qu'est ce qui n'a pas
été fait qu'est ce qui manque d'abord il
faut déconstruire vraiment cette idée
reçue le message qu'on entend de
d'enterrement de rapports du rapport
borloo c'est le rapport boulot moi j'ai
participé j'étais parlementaire à
l'époque député des yvelines l'ancien
ministre de la ville aussi en lui borloo
ancien mise de la ville j'étais dans ces
groupes de travail nous avons travaillé
sur l'image des quartiers sur les luttes
contre les discriminations dont comme
président affirme que trois quarts du
plan est en train d'être mis en oeuvre
au a été mis en oeuvre et la raison il a
raison puisque quand on parle des sites
et éducatives ces issues du rapport
borloo quand on parle de soutien aux
associations de proximité c'est ce que
nous faisons c'est le rapport borloo les
marianne de la république qui sont
évoqués dans le rapport borloo qui sont
ces femmes justement qui prennent aussi
en main la question des quartiers qui
prennent de la place dans l'espace
public c'est issu du rapport borloo donc
le rapport borloo est un rapport qui
n'est pas une feuille de route qui est
un élément qui permet d'enrichir la
construction nos politiques publiques
tout comme l'est le rapport qui a été
rendu par différentes l'institut
montaigne des rapports parlementaires
donc voilà donc oui effectivement de
prison tu as vraiment il ya vraiment eu
du changement cinq ans il y avait une
notion qui était très souvent évoquée
par le président la république c'est
celle de d'assignation à résidence
partant du principe que les gens dans
les quartiers étaient eux mêmes se sont
eux-mêmes prisonniers en fait de leur
propre environnement et ne n'avais pas
au poulet ou devrait pouvoir prendre
leur chance sortir de leur dos lors de
lors de leur zone et de trajectoire
difficile en gaz d'avoir d'accéder est
ce que est ce que ça c'est une notion
c'est quelque chose qui a vraiment
fonctionné est ce que les choses ont
changé en la matière alors vous savez on
va pas régler d'un coup de baguette
magique et en cinq ans problème qui
perdure depuis des décennies en france
par contre nous avons mis des briques
pour enclencher une transformation
durable de nos quartiers quand nous
relançons la rénovation urbaine en
multipliant par deux et en ajoutant 2
milliards d'euros la dernière année sur
les programmes de rénovation urbaine
soit 12 milliards d'euros
d'investissements pour transformer nos
quartiers nous enclenchons cette
transformation quand nous mettons en
place des vrais projets éducatifs de
territoire à travers les sites et
éducatives pour ne laisser finalement
aucun jeune aucun enfant sans solution
là aussi nous enclenchons transformation
nos quartiers et quand nous mettons
l'emploi et le développement économique
au coeur de notre action dans ces
quartiers nous enclenchons une
transformation donc oui effectivement
nous avons commencé ce travail pour
arrêter avec cette assignation à
résidence mais vous savez j'entends trop
de discours aujourd'hui parce que il y a
les faits les actes et les actions c'est
ce que nous mettons en oeuvre et puis il
ya les discours qui rend fait qui
enferme ses jeunes dans une position de
visualisation zemmour je parle non là
pour le coup sûr sur sept dit les
discours de victimisation on assigne à
résidence par des propos qui tire vers
le bas je vous parle de jean-luc
mélenchon et de cette gauche quant à
eric zemmour valérie pécresse marine le
pen elles sont là elles attaquent lll
elle stigmatise ces populations elles
infligent une image d'éditeur pour ces
quartiers qui du coup rendent vraiment
difficile la tâche ce n'est pas rendre
service ni à ses habitants ni à la
république que souad assigné à résidence
par des propos victimaire soit de
stigmatiser avec des propos accablants
terrible et intimiste j'aurais de la
ville est notre invité ce matin françois
xavier le floch et rédacteur en chef de
ouest france depuis rennes à une
question à vous poser sur cette
opposition qui existent peut-être
d'ailleurs entre ville et campagne on
regarde bonjour nadia et vous êtes
ministre de la ville le développement
des métropoles parfois inquiète vous le
savez des territoires ruraux qui peuvent
se sentir oubliés en même temps dans les
métropoles il y à des problématiques
très lourdes vous travaillez évidemment
pour apporter les réponses avec avec les
élus est-ce que
une partie des réponses pour la
politique de la ville ne passe pas par
un développement peut-être plus
harmonieux avec les territoires ruraux
parce que finalement la campagne elle a
beaucoup à apporter à la ville la ville
a peut-être aussi beaucoup à apporter à
la campagne est ce qu'il ne manque pas
d'une politique un peu plus général qui
permettrait de penser en même temps le
développement des campagnes le
développement des villes
monsieur le franc a parfaitement raison
aujourd'hui j'entends aussi dans ce
discours ambiant al'approche de cette
échéance électorale une opposition entre
la ville et la campagne un tri aussi
entre nos concitoyens selon qu'ils
habitent dans la ville où selon qu'ils
habitent dans la campagne nous avons
décidé de traiter des territoires sous
un froid crachin territoriale la
fracture territoriale vous savez nous
avons le premier ministre a présidé un
comité interministériel à la ruralité
juste derrière et l'a présidé un comité
interministériel des villes 5 milliards
à la ruralité 4,6 milliards aujourd'hui
pour la ville pourquoi pour agir là
aussi en profondeur sur les fractures
territoriales et nous avons plus nous
sommes allés beaucoup plus loin sur le
fait de créer des passerelles de
mutualiser des services aujourd'hui vous
avez des bus france service qui apporte
justement l'accès au droit le service
public dans nos territoires qui font à
la fois les quartiers prioritaires de la
ville à la fois la ruralité on a aussi
dans le cadre de nos opérations
quartiers d'été vacances apprenant créer
des liens des ponts entre les jeunes qui
habitent dans les quartiers et les
jeunes qui habitent dans la ruralité
parce qu'il faut arrêter cette
opposition encore une fois elle est
délétère elle ne rend service à personne
alors souvenu que le dessinateur de
ouest france que stéphane verde connaît
bien à une question à vous poser sous
forme de dessin c'est un peu la
tradition de cette émission on écoute on
vient à stéphane bern et a pris
cher nadia madame la ministre comme deux
de nos illustres compatriotes
cavaye debbouze et omar sy ya vous
incarnez la réussite médine trappes dans
les yvelines mais vous êtes surtout le
visage de la politique de la ville du
gouvernement alors la question que je
pose est brûlante face à l' omerta aux
menaces et à la terreur que faut-il
pour stopper la progression inexorable
du salafisme dans nos quartiers et dans
nos villes
je vais très courte pour répondre à
cette question il faut être déterminé
pour répondre en menant des actions
vraiment manière concomitante la
réaffirmation de l'ordre de la sécurité
de la sanction en ayant une action
déterminée avec le ministre de
l'intérieur a misé de la justice pour
punir c'est réaffirmer nos principes
républicains et à la fois mené une
présence une une politique préventive
pour éviter justement que ces jeunes que
ces femmes que ses hommes ne tombent
entre les mains de cette offre
alternative qui est en train de se
construire aujourd'hui dans notre pays
en parallèle de du pacte républicain
donc c'est ce que nous faisons avec
l'ensemble du gouvernement avant la une
de ouest france avant avoir une dernière
chose la crise la crise sanitaire locaux
vides a mis en avant un certain nombre
de difficultés dans les quartiers mais
aussi des formes de solidarité
d'innovation de création
comment on fait pour parler différemment
des quartiers montrer que tout n'est pas
tout n'est pas si compliqué tout n'est
pas si difficile qui se passe aussi des
choses particulières positifs dont on
parle très peu finalement mais bien sûr
il se passe énormément de choses
positives parce que moi je sillonne
aujourd'hui les quartiers de france
évidemment il y a les images de roubaix
que nous avons vu qu'ils nous qui nous
interpelle tous ces longues rama gilet
rose mais il y a aussi des magnifiques
j'ai vu un an d'expérience et gilet rose
la création d'entreprise et ayez
rattrape avec une entreprise une start
up qui a été racheté par michelin et qui
innove aujourd'hui sur justement la
question de la transition écologique âme
au diable et gil rose parce qu'en deux
ans alors les gilet rose là aussi vous
avez des femmes qui depuis des décennies
agissent dans les quartiers pour
apporter du calme de la sérénité aussi
calmer les jeunes pour également donner
d'autres perspectives positives pour
occuper cet espace public drôle ou pas
fait long feu comment deux côtés eh bien
les généreuses mais j'ai décidé
justement de soutenir toutes ces actions
de femmes aujourd'hui sur leur
territoire national avec un fonds qui
leur est dédié d'un minimum de 2
millions d'euros aujourd'hui et pour
pouvoir solliciter ce fonds il faut se
constituer en association ou travailler
avec une association de quartier et
allait se rapprocher des préfectures
pour pouvoir embellir une de ouest
france une page spéciale sur les bons
chiffres de l'apprentissage bonne
nouvelle alors mais oui très bonne
nouvelle ça marche enfin merci stephan
wehrle ouest france on passe à doni
carolis pas car sur ce plateau dans un
instant
bonjour denis carot directeur des
rédactions du groupe nice matin dans un
instant nadia et la ministre chargée de
la ville est à vous si j'ose dire si les
boutiques et le directeur éditorial de
france antilles à une question à poser
depuis fort-de-france en écoute bonjour
me dirai dans le cadre de la politique
de la ville un certain nombre de projets
ont été lancés dans nos territoires à
fort de france et pointe à pitre aux
abymes à saint laurent du maroni à
cayenne certains s'inscrivent dans les
projets coeur de ville pouvez vous nous
faire un point sur ces différents
dossiers sachant qu'un certain nombre
d'entre eux s'inscrivent également dans
la politique du plan de relance
dans cette période de crise sanitaire
et bien tout pour répondre vraiment très
simplement nous avons décidé ce
gouvernement a décidé de ne pas écarter
les antilles en tout cas tous les
territoires d'outre-mer de la politique
que nous portons soit sur la question du
droit commun et c'est la question
justement que vient d'aborder donc
mesure sur le plan de relance soit aussi
en matière de politique de la ville
aujourd'hui tous les territoires qui
sont en difficulté d'outre-mer émargent
aux dispositifs de la politique de la
ville parce que c'est bien une action
qu'il faut mener dans le même temps
c'est à dire transformer durablement nos
coeurs de villes à travers l'action
coeur de ville mais également accompagné
ses habitants vers l'émancipation soit
sur la question de l'éducation soit sur
la question de l'emploi alors denis
carot hier le rapport de la fondation
abbé pierre a été publié oui
effectivement rapport sur le logement et
la fondation abbé pierre nadia estime
que le logement était le parent pauvre
du quinquennat les chiffres sont
parlants à 2,2 millions de demandeurs
d'un logement social et des chiffres de
construction qui sont pas au haut niveau
87000 construction en 2000
et 95 milles en 2021 pourquoi ne tombe
pas pu construire davantage
d'abord il faut juste rappeler que cette
question du logement elle les pâles ou
nouvelle moi même vous savez j'étais
jeune trappistes et j'ai jamais obtenu
un logement social quand j'en avais fait
la demande et que je pouvais y prétend
donc la question n'est pas nouvelle par
contre ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'effectivement on peut toujours faire
mieux et il faut d'ailleurs recherché
toujours les objectifs étaient plus
importants que lors des fixée alors je
vais en scellier quand même à deux
phénomènes cette question de
ralentissement de la construction en
tout cas de ne pas avoir atteint les
objectifs qui étaient fixés d'abord et
une crise sanitaire sans précédent font
pas l'écarter ne faut surtout pas
l'oublier parce qu'elle a eu pour effet
de ralentir la construction savez moi
j'étais encore à beauvais il ya quelques
jours où il y a eu quelques retards dans
la construction parce que les matériaux
n'ont pas été livrés et puis le
confinement donc on a arrêté les
chantiers donc les mises en chantier et
les opérations ont été ralentis par la
crise sanitaire et puis la deuxième le
deuxième effet il faut pas oublier que
l'action elle n'est pas que celle de
l'état ni même que celle des bailleurs
il faut bien délivrer des permis de
construire vous savez quand on est
aujourd'hui à la tête d'une région comme
valérie pécresse qui est à la tête de la
région ile de france et qui ne met pas
un euro dans la construction de
logements logements très sociaux et bien
là où la difficulté pour créer du
logement social l'état ne peut pas tout
faire tout seul il ya une pluralité
d'acteurs et le rapport de la fondation
abbé pierre estime que l'état a privé
les organismes hlm de 6 milliards
d'euros entre 2018 et cette année ce qui
leur collait conduit à utiliser
davantage leurs fonds propres d'une
certaine manière c'est pas le quoi qu'il
en coûte le logement social pour les bus
là vous savez moi je rencontre les
bailleurs sociaux et on a récemment pris
une décision avec le premier ministre de
limiter la construction des logements
sociaux voire très sociaux dans les
quartiers qui endettent contiennent déjà
trop pour éviter justement d'ajouter de
la pauvreté à la pauvreté de lutter
efficacement contre les ghettos j'ai eu
tout le mouvement des bailleurs sociaux
qui nous ont dit vous allez nous limiter
dans la construction en faisant cela
donc en fait la question de la
construction elle n'est pas forcément
lié elle élit évidemment à la santé
financière des bailleurs sociaux mais la
question de la construction des
logements sociaux je peux vous dire qu
est il ya plusieurs effets qui font
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y en n'a tenu qu'un
objectif aujourd'hui qu'est la
construction 250 mille logements sociaux
en deux ans qu'on n'a pas réussi à faire
ces dernières années comment on y arrive
aujourd'hui eh bien on relance tout
simplement aussi vous savez à travers la
rénovation urbaine la rénovation urbaine
quand nous sommes arrivés en 2017
c'était 5 milliards d'euros à l'heure où
je vous parle d'investissements état à
l'heure où je vous parle ce sont 12
milliards d'euros qui sont investis à la
rénovation dans la rénovation urbaine
parce que nous avons augmenté ça va
relancer la construction évidemment
muscleront transforme des quartiers il y
avait donc on relance justement 7,7 en
construction à travers différents
mécanismes la solution elle n'est pas
unique elle est forcément multi play et
c'est ce que nous faisons avec la
ministre du logement senna derrière la
miss chargé de la ville qui est notre
invité politique ce matin on va se
rendre à nouveau à marseille où tom
benoît qui philosophe et essayiste qui à
27 ans va une question à vous poser
depuis marseille il est aussi consultant
auprès de cabinets d'architecturé
on va continuer à parler logement tombe
non à marseille bonjour à la ministre la
politique urbaine qui est menée à
marseille depuis une trentaine d'années
me semble être une politique de
perfusion c'est à dire que tous les
investissements qui sont mis en avant au
niveau national pour marseille sont des
investissements qui ne font que femise
et la précarité dans la ville et dans
les quartiers populaires qui
représentent une grande partie de la
ville je pense qu'on doit investir
j'aimerais savoir si le le gouvernement
macron dont vous représentez un segment
en matière d'urbanisme est prêt à
investir au niveau national dans
marseille pour disposer la deuxième
ville de france à l'avant-garde de la
nation et je précise que vous partez à
marseille juste après l'émission oui
tout à fait c'est pourquoi avec monsieur
benoit a raison quand on la difficulté
de cette ville les difficultés concentre
la ville de marseille nous avons trop
longtemps depuis des années des
décennies agi sous perfusion ce qu'a
souhaité faire le président de la
république s'est déjà donné une vision
pour cette ville il est allé là aussi
présenter toutes les mesures qu'il avait
dans le cadre du marseille en grand
donner une vision pour que cette ville
on révèle les potentiels de cette ville
pour qu'elle rayonne sur le pourtour
méditerranéen et pour cela il faut
s'attaquer au problème
à la racine des problèmes c'est à dire
désenclaver les quartiers c'est pourquoi
nous investissons massivement sur la
question de la mobilité c'est plus d'un
milliard d'euros de l'état qui seront
apportées à cela c'est aussi avoir une
éducation de qualité
recevoir nos enfants dignement dans ces
écoles de marcel c'est pourquoi elle
nous relançons le plan école plus de 250
millions d'euros pour rénover ses écoles
et puis la rénovation urbaine encore une
fois j'insiste énormément parce que
j'étais à la castellane gta et rebelle
évidemment défendu aujourd'hui au jour
alors on ira sur la question des
carrefours de l'entrepreneuriat parce
que là nous irons sur du développement
économique parce qu'il faut donner des
perspectives assez jeunes aujourd'hui
qui en manquent et donc c'est un un
programme aujourd'hui qui touche toutes
les thématiques et c'est ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui le marseille en
grand c'est plusieurs milliards d'euros
qui sont investis pour agir en
profondeur et traiter les maux de cette
ville là aussi on va sur la sueur
l'adjoint la région sud à nice avec à
une de nice-matin aussi denis carot
jours la une de nice matin c'est la
ligne 4 ans en approche le tramway de la
métropole niçoise qui continue à tisser
sa toile et qui arrivera bientôt à
cagnes-sur-mer et et
saint-laurent-du-var vous allez à nice
bientôt si ou pas c'est prévu
effectivement déjà c'était prévu à
quelques temps nager ce que je disais on
a eu quelques
tentatives avortées déplacement mais
nice est dans mes tablettes et ça sera
très prochainement merci denis carot
directeur de la rédaction du groupe nice
matin dans un instant armelle le goff de
20 minutes sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour armelle vous êtes la division la
rédaction de 20minutes mieux vivre la
ville pour les jeunes oui une question
très concrète concernant la vie en ville
vous allez à marseille à une grève des
poubelles à marseille et on voit que la
gestion des déchets dans les grandes
villes et dans les grandes municipalités
est un problème récurrent entre les
habitants et leur municipalité comment
est ce qu'il faudrait agir pour que
cette cette question soit mieux géré
finalement annonce de la fin de cette
grève des éboueurs z l agence vous
partez à marseille c'est fini depuis
hier soir et il ya encore quelques
semaines il était aussi en grève il ya
une vraie problématique aujourd'hui à
marseille sur la situation des éboueurs
et la façon dont le temps de travail
c'est vraiment une question du rythme de
travail qui aujourd'hui est à l'origine
de ces de ces mouvements de grève il y a
dans certains territoires une question
de compétence à qui revient la
compétence du traitement des déchets
alors parfois c'est la métropole parfois
une délégation de compétence et c'est la
ville je crois que marseille en tout cas
est en train de travailler sur une
sortie de crise parce que à un moment
donné il faut vraiment trouver une
solution à cela les discussions entre la
métropole et la ville compte continue
sur la question des transferts de
compétences à travers la réforme
institutionnelle que nous avons sur la
métropole marseillaise est donc là c'est
évidemment un dossier qui est en cours
et sur lesquels nous sommes extrêmement
attentifs oui mais c'est un problème
aussi est par exemple dans une ville
comme paris enfin on voit que oui
exactement mais vraiment pas limité à
marseille non non c'est vraiment pas
mais bon là c'est vrai qu'on parlait de
marseille et on a vu à ces terribles
images quand même parce que derrière
tout ça c'est quand même des habitants
qui en souffrent moi je suis déjà passé
quand il y avait ces grèves d'éboueurs
ces terribles comment fêter les excès de
la lutte politique entre la métropole la
ville de marseille qui se disputent les
responsabilités les prises de
responsabilités sur ces problèmes là et
vous faites-vous de la ministre de la
ville alors moi j'ai de très bons
rapports à la fois avec la métropole est
à la fois avec la ville parce que tout
simplement on est en mode projet vous
savez on fait vraiment là la méthode qui
est celle dans laquelle je me suis
reconnu dans mon et en politique c'est
travailler sur des projets et avoir un
but les prag bouffer du et en même temps
j'ai dû en même temps peut-être un peu
ce qu'elle appelle le maquereau nice
mais c'est totalement ça assez
aujourd'hui comment s'attaque au mans
met de côté toutes nos idéologies
politiques nos positions politiques pour
nous attacher vraiment et nous attaquer
au problème et c'est ce que nous faisons
et ça se passe voilà on avance on avance
et pas toujours évident ce pas toujours
facile mais voilà j'ai bon espoir pour
saab autre question sur la vie au
village il est perçu il ya eu pas mal
d'études sur le sujet ces dernières
années comme un espace très masculin
comment on fait pour que les femmes se
sentent en sécurité dans un espace
urbain qu'elle ait un regard vous portez
sur ses études et sur cette question
vous avez totalement raison que des
études d'ailleurs qui sont reprises par
pas mal de d'organismes de l'analyse
aussi de la ville eh bien on agit sur
plusieurs leviers d'abord c'est envisagé
en fait porter le regard de son quartier
comme si c'était notre maison parce que
l'environnement quand on doit se sentir
en sécurité d'avoir suffisamment
d'éclairage éviter les et mavs les
éviter les regroupements aussi deux
jeunes dans des halls d'immeuble qui est
un certain nombre de mesures a mené à la
fois sur la question de la rénovation
urbaine la transformation de l'urbain et
à la fois agir sur l'humain et bien tout
simplement en offrant d'autres activités
à ces jeunes que de se retrouver dans un
hall d'immeuble c'est aussi permettre
aux femmes de récupérer d'investir
l'espace public vous savez on parle
beaucoup de marseille et j'étais
justement dans le 3e arrondissement de
marseille où des femmes ont décidé
d'investir un espace pour faire reculer
les trafics de drogue et pour que cet
espace soit récupéré par les familles
par les enfants qui jouent au vélo
qu'ils puissent jouer au ballon et bien
ça marche et c'est ce qu'il ya ce qui
m'a conduit à prendre la décision de
mettre en place ce fonds pour les gilet
rose et puis armelle le goff lé
baromètre de la jeunesse dans la
campagne présidentielle dans 20 minutes
exactement vingt minutes ouest france et
les journaux de loire ont décidé de
lancer un baromètre de mobilisation de
la jeunesse autour de la question en fin
de la campagne présidentielle
et il ya une question quand même qui est
importante
il y a un enjeu autour du vote des
jeunes aujourd'hui les 18 22 ans selon
notre baromètre ne sont que 38% à dire
qu'ils vont aller voter lors de
l'élection présidentielle alors vous
allez vous investir auprès d' emmanuel
macron dans sa campagne qui n'a pas
encore fait sa déclaration de
candidature vous savez où il va la faire
d'ailleurs non et c'est absolument pas
le moment aujourd'hui de parler de ce
sujet là je crois que les sujets et
internationales 20 69 sur 100 il 60% de
la jeunesse ne s'intéressent pas la
campagne présidentielle et ça c'est un
vrai sujet ça c'est terrible je peux
vous dire que c'est terrible parce que
ça montre à quel point notre démocratie
est en crise ça et c'est ce que je dis
aux jeunes moi quand je vais sur les
territoires et qui me disent qu'ils ne
vont pas voter jeudi vous vous privez
d'un pouvoir juste extraordinaire on
vous offre la république vous offre ce
pouvoir de participer à la vie
démocratique
et puis en quelque sorte de faire part
de votre accord de votre désaccord et où
est donc par rapport à un programme qui
vous est proposée par rapport aux 6 à ce
qu'on la vision que nous avons de notre
pays et de votre avenir donc mont mau
mau il est très simple c'est aller voter
quel que soit le bulletin que vous
mettez dans l'urne allez voter alors tv
78 une question à vous poser ces villes
friederici rédacteur en chef de cette
chaîne des yvelines qui est partenaire
de cette émission elle exigerait par
thierry barbedette qui pilote aussi
cette émission il revient sur le kärcher
regard des médias bonjour le 5 janvier
dernier à valérie pécresse déclaré
vouloir ressortir le karcher de la cab
pour vous qui avez grandi à trappes il
s'agit d'une nouvelle humiliation mais
au delà des déclarations des uns et des
autres il ya des chiffres là 13 % de
plus sur le nombre de mises en cause
pour trafic de stupéfiants 12 %
supplémentaires de faits constatés pour
les coups et blessures volontaires
des chiffres qui ne concerne pas
uniquement bien évidemment ce que l'on
appelle des quartiers mais pensez vous
que le gouvernement puisse féliciter de
son bilan sur les banlieues alors que
l'en de département des yvelines par
exemple on recense quotidiennement des
faits de violence dans les cités on l'a
vu l'an dernier à trappes notamment avec
le commissariat a pris d'assaut par une
quarantaine d'adolescents
d'abord moi j'ai envie de dire à aller
enfin en est le plein de tout en
écoutant les chiffres qu'a rappelé
wilfried ritchie c'est quelque part une
bonne nouvelle parce que ça montre que
notre politique que nous menon en
matière de sécurité fonctionne puisqu'il
ya beaucoup plus de trafiquants qui sont
interpellés puisqu'il ya beaucoup plus
d'arrestations qui sont opérés donc
notre politique de sécurité fonctionne
quant aux expressions utilisées par
valérie pécresse elle montre une seule
chose c'est qu'elle est complètement
incompétente pour traiter ces fonds donc
on fait une polémique on ressort une des
expressions d'un tiroir il a été
contre-productif d'ailleurs qui n'a pas
du tout fonctionné qui n'a absolument
pas marché et donc nous préférons
évidemment plutôt que d'utiliser des
expressions vieille comme le monde nous
attaquer aux vrais problèmes et je pense
comme des habitants c'est ce qu'ils
attendent aujourd'hui dernière question
amène la question de la jeunesse est
toujours selon notre baromètre vous
disiez dire aux jeunes d'aller voter
mais 52% des 18-30 ans pensent que leur
situation personnelle ne s'améliorera
pas si leur candidat est élu ce
désenchantement par rapport à la
politique il interroge quand même il
interroge parce que depuis trop
longtemps vous savez moi même je suis
une déçu des politiques c'est ce qui a
fait mon engagement politique j'étais
dans la société civile une jeune dans
les quartiers une jeune femme j'étais
comme eux dans un pertes parfois un peu
de sens de boussole et un moment donné
on décide justement peut-être d'opérer
de participer à quelque chose qui
pourrait être une transformation et un
changement et je me suis engagé en
politique donc cette colère il ne faut
pas qu'elle soit justement ton
contre-productive soit justement pas
engager la norme politique engagé voire
politique mais vous savez nos jeunes
notamment dans les quartiers ils sont
extrêmement politique parce qu'ils
s'engagent dans milieu associatif parce
qu'ils ont décidé de créer des
entreprises ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils
ne s'intéressent pas au débat politique
c'est que tout simplement ils ont besoin
de preuve que l'action que les promesses
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont tenus par les
politiques qu'elles soient tenus et je
ne veux pas aujourd'hui n'était pas
l'objet mais en tout cas de vous faire
la promotion de ce que nous avons fait
mais en terme de bilan nous avons fait
ce que nous avons dit que ce que nous
avons promis de faire aux français je
pense que là c'est peut-être un début de
réponse à leur apporter fit la une de
20minutes 10h oui tout à fait importante
on la voit dans un instant
voilà je les mois merci armelle le goff
happy hours on passe à sylvia garcia de
tv5 monde dans un instant
[Musique]
bonjour sylvia garcia journaliste à la
rédaction de tv5monde pour les questions
un peu plus internationale dans cette
affaire avouez on va s'intéresser en un
petit peu à votre ville la ville de
trappes la ville dans laquelle vous avez
grandi au sein d'une famille d'origine
marocaine de quatre enfants une mère au
foyer un père ouvrier c'est un îlot de
pauvreté à côté de la splendeur de
versailles est-ce que la banlieue ça
raconte l'histoire de france et une
france qui a du mal avec son passé avec
son histoire aussi ça raconte une partie
de notre histoire de france et et moi
vous savez vous avez rappeler d'où je
venais j'ai vécu de très belles années à
trappes où la mixité sociale était là où
l'ouvrier côtoyé l'infirmier le
directeur d'école et ça a été vraiment
mis à mal par différentes politiques par
différentes décisions qui ont été prises
et qui ont organisé de manière peut-être
volontaire ou involontaire et bien à
cette question de ghettoïsation et
aujourd'hui deux décennies de politique
de la ville qui n'ont pas marché c'est
pas une question que de politique de la
ville c'est aussi comment on compense sa
ville vous savez la politique de la
ville elle intervient sur que sur des
champs effectivement c'est une politique
interministérielle transversale mais qui
vient en complément du droit commun ça
veut dire que le droit commun un moment
donné n'a pas été efficace ou alors il
s'est retiré et la politique de la ville
est venu un petit peu justement
supporter si nous revoilà souvent on est
faut souvent la banlieue au reste de la
france c'est une arracheuse juste
lecture juste pour revenir peut-être et
ensuite je vous répondrais sur cette
question mais juste revenir sur la
politique de la ville je pense que sans
politique de la ville je ne sais pas si
je serais aujourd'hui à votre micro et à
la place à laquelle je suis donc elle a
apporté des réponses elle permet
d'accompagner quand vous regardez bien
le flux elle permet d'accompagner des
cohortes de public qui ont bénéficié de
la politique de la ville et mais par
contre elle n'a pas réels ne répondent
pas aux transformations profondes qu'il
faut parler parce que ça c'est le droit
commun et c'est ce que nous faisons pas
les centres à leur ont parlé tout à
l'heure de marc si on parlait de jamel
debbouze qui sont nés à trappes comme
vous à côté de ça près de 70 jeunes sont
partis de cette ville pour faire le
jihad en syrie c'est un record en europe
et un proportionnellement à la
population
à quel moment l'état a failli à quel
moment la politique de la ville a failli
par rapport à ces jeunes c'est pas la
politique de la ville qui a failli c'est
c'est collectivement a saisi la
politique de la ville suniula politique
de la ville leur propose ce n'est pas
que l'état s'est en fait notre société
notre pays qui a failli parce que quand
vous avez aujourd'hui des jeunes qui
sont attirés par des discours comme ça
de haine contre la république et qu'ils
sont qui sont à l'écouté de cela c'est
qu'à un moment donné la république ne le
rappelle comment marc ona paraît que
vous êtes ministre vous allez dans un
quartier vous êtes forcément entouré de
crs de cordon de sécurité lui pas
nécessaire du préfet qui est là est ce
que vous arrivez à vous oubliez tout ça
et aller vers eux tout simple en a parlé
avec eux vous êtes de trappes vous même
vous êtes il est dans ce quartier vous
avez grandi dans je crois dans un
habitations une habitation à loyer
modéré
on doit ajouter les qualités en réalité
pour leur parler mais vous êtes ministre
la république donc forcément perçu à des
jupes différemment vous avez totalement
raison et est déjà là je retourne très
régulièrement à trappes puisque ma mère
y habite toujours j'habite à quelques
quelques doigts de fièvre m'a de devoir
aller elle et elle extrêmement fier
vraiment ce que mon père l'aurait été
s'il était encore de ce monde et donc
j'y vais sans cordon de sécurité à
trappes comme quoi j'ai entendu un
responsable politique récemment pour pas
le nommer jordan bardella qui dit que tu
rappes est un territoire d'une
république islamique et bien non je
l'invite à venir les découvrir cette
vive le démontage et vous alors vous
êtes trop dangereux lui ment pas il
m'arrive de prendre la voiture et d'y
aller tout seul aux grandes arches pas
vraiment là pour le coup tout le monde
est en stress mais pas moi vraiment jeu
j'y retourne très très régulièrement au
moins deux fois par semaine pour tout
vous dire et quand je vais à la
rencontre de ces jeunes jardi tout
simplement sa vie à quelques années
j'étais à votre place vous j'étais à
votre place au collège le village au
lycée de la plaine de neuf qui encore
cité récemment avec ses menaces de
preuve que je n'ai pas connu que je n'ai
pas vécu puisque à l'époque justement il
y avait sept 7 cette mixité il n'y avait
pas ces questions identitaires que veut
bien nous imposer nous infliger cette
extrême droite ça n'existait pas à
l'époque c'était
des parcours de vie qui se rencontraient
et ce que je veux dire à ces jeunes
encore une fois il n'y a pas de fatalité
ne vous enfermez pas dans les discours
de ceux qui voudraient vous enfermez qui
soit extrême droite s'exprime de façon
un peu différente parfois sur le plan
international il ya un sujet qui fait
réagir dans ces territoires politique de
la ville c'est le conflit israélo
palestinien
ces dernières années des violences en
plus éclaté en marge de manifestations
en soutien à gaza est ce que vous
comprenez que certaines certains jeunes
projettent leur frustration sur cette
question au proche orient moi je ne peut
de toute façon pas comprendre que les
combats internationaux se sont fait une
raison importante et une remontée comme
étant notre terrain car ce que nous
sommes avant tout des france dont vous
dites de concerts france a dit que c'est
maintenant et parce que la question à
nos rabais ya quelques années maintenant
maintenant vous savez ces jeunes qui
aujourd'hui milite pour des causes qui
leur semble injuste c'est parce que
quelque part il y a un sentiment d'être
traitée de manière injuste dans leur
propre pays et donc il ya un repli qui
se fait identitaire et c'est pourquoi je
vous dis que cette question et du
identitaire nous est infligée imposé qu
elle soit d'extrême gauche ou d'extrême
droite dans notre pays et qui fait
perdre la boussole à ces jeunes dans
notre territoire la question aujourd'hui
de la justice elle peut être menée ici
et pour moi elle doit être d'une justice
territoriale d'une geste hills pour
réparer les inégalités à la racine et
l'énergie qu'ils déploient sur
l'importation des problèmes
internationaux eh bien il faudrait qu'on
les déploie aujourd'hui ensemble pour
réduire ces fractures aujourd'hui
territoriale et sociale dans notre pays
je la question très dernière question
très vite vu rebondir sur la question
dès que vous évoquez les problématiques
internationales quand vous étiez député
vous étiez un pilier du groupe d'amitié
france maroc à l'assemblée on sait que
les relations soient un petit peu tendu
entre la france et le maroc c'est une
crise qui ne dit pas son nom il il ya
des tensions vous savez dans les
rapports internationaux avec les pays il
y en avait dans le précédent quinquennat
avec avec françois hollande mais moi je
crois là les relations sont plus tard
quand même rêver d'aller au maroc et
vous allez-vous oui oui mais j'ai des
mes grands parents qui sont encore de ce
monde est donc temps qu'ils sont là
je retournerai les voir évidemment et
puis je suis attaché aux 6 à 7 à cette
culture aussi marocaine que que nono mes
parents nous ont transmis mais mais
quelque part vous savez je suis
évidemment très optimiste sur les
relations avec enfin avec le maroc
puisque notre histoire elle est
extrêmement ancienne elle n'est pas
nouvelle l'amitié est tout de même forte
entre les peuples et je peux vous dire
qu'au maroc eh bien ils sont fiers de
parler français et ils sont fiers aussi
de venir en france pour étudier ils sont
bien fiers aussi pour venir de tourisme
et puis à nous effectivement
d'entretenir ses relations diplomatiques
partout
sanitaire malheureusement n'être pas
forcément les relations vous êtes le
ministre de la ville vous êtes une femme
dans ce gouvernement est ce que vous
souhaitez que le président de la
république se soit candidat déclare sa
candidature dans un dans un quartier où
pas à moi de toute façon je souhaite que
qui se déclarent quel que soit l'endroit
je pense que c'est pas vraiment
important je souhaite que le président
soit vous allez faire partie de la paie
encore une ida en tout cas je ferai tout
comme j'ai fait en 2017 pour qu'il soit
réélu parce que je pense que c'est
l'homme qu'il nous faut pour ce pays
continuer ce projet de transformation
que nous avons commencé depuis cinq ans
c'est un programme je pense au moins
pour une décennie donc je le souhaite
caisse pour le moment et faire pour la
prairie ligue et le escaut à la lettre
préoccupant est ce que veulent être
candidats aux élections législatives par
exemple je continue évidemment cet
engagement politique je continuerai la
politique tant que je serai utile à
sebring oui j'ai poussier accroché à la
politique je pense que j'en ferai pas
toute ma vie
parce que ça demande
d'être extrêmement investi à la tâche et
d'être extrêmement connecté au problème
et ont créé vous étiez ministre il reste
quelques on est rentré dans la petite
minute convient d'en semer mais c'est
une grande vraiment une grande entre
surprises d'abord et puis un honneur et
une fierté on apprend sa part au corps
est dans l'homme blanc voilà venez vous
êtes convoqué enfin convoqué invité
benjamin ion dieu à venir vous voir et
puis vous attendu non enfin
j'avais quelques quelques sons de voix
là de l'intérêt que portait aussi et le
président est certaine donc à ce que je
faisais au parlement mais on s'y attend
pas et puis vous savez c'est d'abord un
honneur ensuite une fierté que qu'un
président de la république un premier
ministre vous fassent confiance pour
porter des sujets quand même qui me sont
des avancées avec des trucs de trappes à
7 minutes j'avais la première chose à
laquelle on pense c'est que en ce on se
revoit vingt ans peut-être ou trente ans
en arrière dans cette toujours dans
cette danse est cité attraper et de se
dire quel chemin parcouru mais encore
une fois c'est pourquoi je vous dis pour
les jeunes dans nos quartiers il n'y a
pas de fatalité on peut réussir à l'on
peut pas tout sept ministres mais en
tout cas on peut réussir dans sa vie on
peut être chef d'entreprise on peut être
voilà crée aussi une association peut on
peut réussir aujourd'hui et c'est le
message que j'ai envie de de délivrer
aujourd'hui voilà c'était nadia et la
ministre chargée de la ville qui était
notre invité politique aujourd'hui merci
s'il ya garcia on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine jeudi en direct avec elisabeth
bornes la ministre du travail par là
évidemment télétravail et retour au
travail en france au revoir à tous les
programmes continus sur tv5 monde
[Musique]